[MUSIC PLAYING]
K. MICHAEL HAYS: We begin with an aphorism by the Viennese 20th-century
architect Adolf Loos. Loos writes, &quot;If we find a mound six feet long and three
feet wide in the forests, formed into a pyramid, shaped by a shovel,
we become serious and something says, 'someone lies buried here.'
That is architecture.&quot;
Now, there are several things to attend to in that little passage.
First of all, it seems to be a sort of unprepared encounter.
We come upon a mound in the forest.
But immediately, we see that the mound has been shaped.
Someone has constructed it, and someone has constructed it
into the shape of a pyramid.
The mound is not actually a pyramid.
The pyramid is something that we have to construct
in the architectural imagination.
But someone has given us markers.
They've indexed the act of construction.
Loos says, &quot;It's been shaped by a shovel.&quot;
So there are tools involved with the construction.
The tools indicate that there's a craft involved-- there's technique involved.
So we have an encounter that involves the architectural imagination,
constructing a genre or a type, which is the pyramid-- this particular kind
of construction,
and we have craft or technique involved.
But the shape of the mound, and what we call
its indexicality-- that is, it's marking the fact that it's constructed--
and all these other features that Loos recounts,
those are associated features.
Those are sort of part of the sensuous experience.
They're really sort of encrustations to the real object,
which is a tomb or a pyramid or a grave of some sort.
Then Loos says we become serious.
This is important.
The consequence of the encounter is, first of all, an architectural affect.
We become serious.
The mound, the shape of the mound, the appearance of the mount,
has affected us.
All these encrusted features have an architectural affect,
and, only then, do we conceptualize.
Only then, do we theorize someone lies buried here,
and the summation of that encounter is the conclusion:
&quot;That is architecture.&quot;
Now, what is the &quot;that&quot;?
The &quot;that,&quot; which is architecture, is not the actual experience.
The sensual experience has an effect, but the &quot;that,&quot;
which is architecture-- the real object of that is withdrawn.
It's inaccessible.
We don't actually experience the &quot;that.&quot;
The real object of architecture is autonomous from my encounter with it.
The sensuous object is part of the encounter.
The sensuous qualities inhabit the encounter.
We can understand this:
if I close my eyes, the sensual object vaporizes, evaporates,
but the real object, the &quot;that,&quot; which is architecture, is still there.
It has its own autonomy, its own identity separate from the encounter.